la confiance des canadiens étaient déjà
ébranlée elles pourraient être longues a
rétabli les sénateurs avaient organisé
des voyages payés à même les fonds
publics mariage partie pêche soirée de
financement politique problème de
résidence
michael ferguson remet en question des
dépenses injustifiées qui totalisent
plus de neuf cent soixante dix huit
mille dollars président du sénat
s'efforce de minimiser les dégâts
c'est un portrait du sénat à 2011 2012
c'est pas une portait du sénat 2015 des
neuf dossiers soumis à la grc celui de
pierre hugues boisvenu les problèmes de
résidence le sénateur a réclamé 16 mille
dollars en frais de résidence secondaire
à ottawa alors que dans les faits selon
le rapport
il s'agissait de sa résidence principale
vérificateur lui reproche aussi d'avoir
mêlé son rôle de sénateur et ses
activités de défense des droits des
victimes incluant la promotion son livre
total de la facture 38 mille dollars
le sénateur boisvenu conteste les
conclusions les son avenir au sénat
demeure incertain j'ai signé tout à
l'heure une lettre de référence du
dossier au comité de discipline pour
avoir une enquête conseiller en éthique
sur le comportement du sang arabe
revenus cinq cas de déclaration de
résidence jugées inexactes par le
vérificateur sont aux mains de la grc
tout ça en plein procès de mcdo fille ou
plusieurs chefs d'accusation repose
justement sur le même enjeu des
améliorations importantes s'imposent aux
plaintes de la surveillance de
l'imputabilité et de la flore le fait
que les sénateurs se gèrent eux-mêmes en
établissant leurs propres règles il
recommande de créer un organisme
dépendant pour surveiller leurs dépenses
le président du sénat a beau promettre
la transparence
il n'est pas prêt pour autant à endosser
un organisme de surveillance indépendant
j'ai aucune réticence évidemment c'est
comme
président du sénat c'est pas moi qui
prends cette décision finale mais le
leader du gouvernement au sénat ouvre la
porte
on a déjà commencé à regarder qu'est ce
qui se fait dans d'autres juridictions
calmer la tempête au sénat s'annonce
difficile parce culièrement à l'aube
d'une campagne électorale
ce rapport et les réponses ci mais qui
ont suivi vient de donner des munitions
à ceux qui comme le npd réclame des
changements radicaux
et si marc godbout radio canada à ottawa